watching our subject for this evening
going to extremes
what did i say
in the beginning god created the heaven
and the earth
and the earth was without form and void
and darkness was upon the face of the
deep
and the spirit of god moved upon the
face of the waters
and god said
let there be light
and there was light
and god saw the light that it was good
and god divided the light from the
darkness
and god called the light day and the
darkness he called night
and evening and the morning
were the first day
for by him were all things created
that are in heaven and that in earth
visible and invisible
whether they be thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers all things were
created by him and for him and he is
before all things and by him all things
consist
so remember the sabbath day to keep it
holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work but the seventh day is the sabbath
of the lord thy god in it thou shalt not
do any work
thou not thy son nor thy daughter thy
man's servant nor thy maidservant nor
thy cattle nor thy stranger that is
within thy gates for in six days the
lord made heaven and earth the sea and
all that in them is
and rested the seventh day
wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath
day and hallowed it
happy sabbath everyone
god is good
and all the time
psalm 100 verse 5 for the lord is good
let me ask you this
have you seen the goodness of god in
your life merge your hair
all right so have i i ought to raise two
hands
well let's try it again god is good
come on god is good
and all the time
you know he really is
nice to see my people made it safely god
bless you he really is
when god blesses us
he's good come on can you say amen for
blessings
when god punishes us he's good can you
say a man for punishment
without punishment there's no character
development are you with me we don't
like the punishment but it's necessary
when god answers our prayers
come on
he's good when he says no
he's good
is there a time when god isn't good no
the bible says in psalm 145 verse 17 the
lord is righteous in all his ways and
holy in all his works everything god
does
is right
when he stood by and watched christ die
on the cross
he was right
when he destroyed the world by a flood
when he incinerated sodom and gomorrah
he was right
god
is always
right
we
are wrong
but you see when adam and eve sinned and
god came down in genesis 3 he said to
adam where are thou and he said i heard
thy voice in the garden and i was afraid
because i was naked and i hid myself and
god said to him who told thee that thou
was naked hast thou eaten of the tree
whereof i commanded thee that i should
not eat and the man said the woman whom
thou gave is to be with me she gave me
of the tree and i did it and the lord
god said unto the woman what is this
that thou has done and the woman said
the serpent beguiled me sin created in
mankind the natural urge to blame
someone else
and so instead of blaming ourselves
for being harsh
and unkind or whatever else we blame god
instead of blaming ourselves for being
hard-hearted we blame the law
are you with me
so we say the law is difficult the law
is hard
the bible says his commandments are not
grievous
they are easy
when this hard heart is softened by the
grace of god
how are you
you look nice thanks for coming is there
anyone present who's not the seventh-day
adventist and i mean you're not a
seventh-day adventist
anyone
all right
and we're not online i believe are we
online
we are online oh well let me greet those
who are watching us online wherever you
are we thank god for modern technology
that allows us to worship in this
building and be watched in countries all
over the world god bless those who are
with us online i neglected to welcome
you last night forgive me for that i am
glad that i have been made aware that
god's people online are watching our
subject for this evening going to
extremes
what did i say
this side what was our subject last
night
that side are they right
all right okay yes they're right the
cost of salvation and tonight going to
extremes do three favors for me they're
very small uh if you have one of these
you're not using it as a so-called bible
could you turn it off
please
so it does not ring
let me check mine so you don't have to
say physician heal thyself
all right
okay it's off
favorite number two while i'm speaking
and for those of you online you may be
in your homes comfortably seated
preserve reverence
because the fact that we're online does
not make god less holy
are you following me god is holy whether
you're using zoom facebook youtube vimeo
whatever we use the holiness of god does
not change so if you're online relaxing
on your couch we're worshiping the god
of heaven and earth let's preserve
reverence can you say amen
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord put your words in
that man's mouth
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord
put forth his hand and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i
that's god have put my words in thy
mouth god is divine his words are divine
and he teaches he touches my lips made
of dirt and earth
my human weak mouth and he puts his
words defined words in a human mouth
that i thank god for that honor that
he'll give me that he gives me to speak
for him and so you pray and say god
please
that man needs help you'll be right put
your words
in that man's mouth
and fear number three
think
isaiah 1 18 come now let us do what
reason together set the lord think
i frequently say if we would think we
would not eat the things we eat
if we would stop and why am i what am i
eating
this thing has been dead for three weeks
why am i eating it
you know seasoning does not bring a dead
animal alive are you following me no
you're not with me you didn't like what
i just said but if we would think we
would not eat the things we eat
if we would think we would not drink the
things we drink
you know you can use coca-cola to remove
rust
do you know that
but people drink it by the gallon
into the delicate stomachs
if we would think
we would not date some of the people we
date
if we would stop
and
think we would not have the friends we
have
let me really upset somebody now
if we would think
we would not attend some of the churches
we attended
favor number three
think let's pray
father in heaven
we've come for one reason to worship you
as we bow in your presence there god if
we've sinned against you forgive us
father forgive us quickly
wash us in the blood of your son
and make us clean
we humble ourselves before you father
particularly me because my burden is to
deliver this message on your behalf
use me regard i really mean that
i remove myself and i allow you father
to stand in this desk
let your voice be my voice
your words my words
let the humility of christ be mine let
the compassion of christ be mine but let
the boldness of christ be mine
bless all those who listening in person
and online a special blessing on all
children who are listening their god
and if there's someone online who is not
the seventh-day adventist a special
blessing on that person
father now use may i pray as a musician
uses an instrument in jesus name let
god's people say amen and amen
genesis 1 verse 26
genesis 1 verse 26 is well known
i should just say it you know it very
well and god said let us make man how
in our image come on after our likeness
stop
let us make man
in our image after our likeness which
means clearly if i am made in the image
of god i should look like god
ella white writes
patriarchs and prophets page 45
paragraph two man was to bear god's
image both in outward resemblance and in
character
did you get that
let me say it again
man was to bear god's image both in
outward resemblance and in character
meaning when god made adam and eve
somehow they looked like god outwardly
but more importantly they were to look
like god inwardly in character let us
make man
in our image
if adam and eve had not sinned their
behavior would have reflected god
and god's behavior would have been seen
in them
are you following me all right let's
take a look at some
requests or some demands that jesus made
of us who claim to be made in the image
of god at least spiritually go to
john 13.
i love the book of john very much it's
not my favorite book that's genesis but
i love john
take time to study the book of john you
will be greatly blessed there are four
gospels matthew mark luke and john the
first three are called synoptic gospels
because they tend to see things alike
that's what synoptic means to see a like
john is so different it is not a
synoptic gospel it stands by itself
because his view of christ is so
elevated he begins with christ as with
the father from eternity in the
beginning was the word and the word was
with god and the word was god and so
john is a very special gospel written by
the man who was closest to christ and
elohim says of all the disciples he most
perfectly reflected the character of
jesus
so when you read john you're reading a
word a book written by someone who was
closest to christ than anyone else who
was a human being john 13 reading from
verse 13.
when you found it say amen
you call me master and lord
and you say well for so i am
if i then your lord and master have
washed your feet finish the verse
he also ought to wash one another's feet
now read 15 carefully for i have done
what
given you an example that you should do
as i have done to you now question for
you what is the purpose of an example
to follow
an example is not simply to be admired
then it becomes a painting or a work of
art an example is to be copied
an example is a guide
how should i build this church look at
that one
are you following me and build it the
same way this becomes an example that
guides the construction of that church
jesus says i have given you an example
that you should do as i have done to you
what's the example
humility
then we know that god is what kind of
god
a humble god
as a matter of fact the most humble
being in the universe is god
even though he's the most powerful
now you give someone in the church a
little office let's say assistant deacon
and the person's chest begins to swell
the person no longer recognize the poor
members of the church because the person
is so delighted with this position of
authority god who made heaven and earth
is humble
and so i have given you an example that
he should do as i have done to you in
the area of humility we are to be like
god because god was first humble he can
require that of us as an expression of
his image let's go to john 15. our
subject
is what
going to extremes very good john 15.
if i give you the first let's pray again
father in heaven as i continue restrain
my carnal nature god that your glory
alone will become my focus in jesus name
i pray amen john 15
12 read carefully read microscopically
if you have the king james version read
with me what does that say this is my
commandment come on that you love one
another how
as i have loved you
look at that verse again
it says this is my suggestion
that you love one another
this is my advice
that no this is my idea
what is it
a commandment now does a commandment
require how you feel
no
you know i don't feel that like not
killing today let me kill my neighbor no
comma obedience does not require
feeling
that's why we're commanded to forgive
whether you feel like forgiving or not
ah that just went over your heads or
under your chair
the bible says forgive us our debts how
as we forgive
we are to forgive whether we feel like
forgiving or not
we are to return a tithe finish my words
whether we feel like returning it or not
obeying god is not connected to how we
feel
this is my commandment
no discussion
you either do it or you don't that you
love one another how as i have loved you
then you may legitimately ask how does
god love us read verse 13
nice and loud
greater love have no man than this come
on that a man lay down his life for his
friends now god says in verse 12 of john
15 or jesus
this is my commandment that you love one
another as i have loved you and as i
said you can ask well jesus how did you
love us that cross
the greatest expression of love is the
sacrifice of the greatest thing to you
that is your life and so jesus said i
have loved you because i've come to die
for you that's how i want you to love by
the way the bible says that elsewhere go
to first john chapter three
john chapter three we read verse 16 our
subject is what going
to extremes
it's 7 30 on the dot
i'll release you by 8 o'clock
first john that's right chapter 3
what verse did i say
do you have that
now some of you still looking all right
come on come on
first john
chapter 3 verse 16
that's right
and i appreciate you asking me to tell
you again i appreciate that very much
i'm not here to give a performance i'm
here to worship with you so when you
don't get it ask me i'll say it again
are you with me so thank you very much
for doing that
first john 3 16 what does the bible say
hereby come on
perceive with the love of god because he
laid down his life for us now you finish
the verse
we ought to
lay down our lives for the brethren
let me put this scenario to you
you and a church member are walking down
the street one night
someone jumps from the alley with a gun
pointed at your friend your church
member your brother your sister what do
you
do what would jesus do
now he's pointing the gun at the church
member you're walking with
what would jesus do
based on john 15 13 greater love hath no
man than this that a man lay down his
life for his friends what would jesus do
he would stand between that gun and his
brother or sister
if you have to kill someone
kill me
that's love
greater love
hath no man than this that a man laid
down his life for his friends now we go
back to john 15 13 greater love hath no
man than this as we just read that he
laid down his life for his friends this
is how i love says god i love
sacrificially
i love to the point of giving all that i
have and that is my life now since we
were made originally in god's image that
is how god requires us to love
because that's the way he is
so in the church building offering is
lifted
how should we give
you're talking so softly i can't hear
you
how should we give
sacrificially
let me digress slightly
when a church gives sacrificially you
don't have to have a fair and a sale and
a concert
is this mic working
you don't need you don't need concert
and fairs and and bingo and lottery
you give sacrificially and then god
multiplies what you've given as you
multiply the fish and the bread
others require those activities to raise
funds we give sacrificially
because that's the way god gives
god is humble we are to be humble god
loves sacrificially we are to love
sacrificially all right let's go to john
17.
our subject
going to extremes
and give your life for someone isn't
extreme
john 17
let's read verse 11.
i read from the king james version of
the bible
when you have that say amen
read with me if you have my virgin and
now i am no more in the world but these
are in the world and i come to thee holy
father keep through thy known name those
whom thou has given me finish the verse
that they may be one how
as we are
what is christ praying for
oneness unity where
in the church
a place where you seldom find unity but
that's where christ wants him
in the church
if a church discusses should we paint
the wall blue or green it takes church
board meetings business meetings church
breaks up into doing starts another
church we cannot agree on whether it's
blue or green that's how the church
functions
churches break up what kind of carpet
should we use break up
christ wants us to be one how the same
way he come on and his father are one
that is going to an extreme
what arguments do the father and the son
have none
and you say to yourself this is
impossible that's why we're going to
extremes
when there was a disagreement in the
early church in acts chapter 6 when the
grecian women complained against the
hebrew women because the grecian women
were not ministered to as generously the
bible says then the twelve called the
multitude of the disciples unto them and
said it is not reason for us to leave
the word of god and serve tables
wherefore brethren look ye out among you
seven men of honest report full of the
holy ghost and wisdom whom we may
appoint over this business but we will
give ourselves continually to prayer and
to the study of the ministry of the word
the bible says and the saying pleased
the whole multitude
everyone agreed
because that early church was full of
what
the holy spirit the bible says the
saying pleased the whole multi now
that's a rarity
but we can get to that point
that there may be one
as we are go to verse 22 of john 17.
are you there
read with me
and the glory which thou gives me i have
given them that they may be one you
finish it even as we are one keep
reading 23 i in them and thou in me that
they may be made perfect in one and that
the world may know that thou has what
and has loved them come on that's thou
has loved me
the same way we are one says christ of
him and his father the church is to be
one
what god requires of us
is what he is
let me say that by adding this he does
not require us to be divine are you with
me
we cannot be divine you can't create god
but we must have the very character of
god to the degree that the created being
can express it
and so ellen white writes in education
page 18 paragraph four higher than the
highest human thought can reach is god's
ideal for his children what is that
height godliness god-likeness is the
goal to be rich to be rich means
constantly climbing
and so in humility john 13 we are to be
like god because god is humble in love
we are to be like god because god is
love in unity we are to be like god and
the son because they are one
let's go to first john chapter 2.
it's already 20 minutes to eight
going to extremes
first john chapter two
let's read for six
first john two verse six
do you have that
let me pray again that god continue to
be with me please i pray in the name of
jesus amen
he that saith he abideth in him finish
the verse
yes he that sith he abideth in him ought
himself also sort of walk even as he
walked it doesn't mean that jesus walked
like this and you'd walk like that it
means his lifestyle
if you say you are in christ you must
live like christ
what's the standard for lifestyle the
very life of jesus
it was not materialistic it was not
self-centered it all had to do with
being a blessing to others and thereby
glorifying his father and so he could
say in john 17 4 i have glorified thee
on the earth i have finished the work
which thou gives me to do he can say in
john 8 29 he that have sent me is with
me the father hath not left me alone for
i do always those things that please him
this is the lifestyle required of us
does that dress glorify god
does that diet glorify god
does does my spending habit glorify god
jesus said everything i do my first
thought is god
and he requires that of us
let's look at one more example of going
to extremes revelation 3 verse 21
the very last book of the bible also
written by john
on the isle of patmos
i've often wondered when john was on the
isle of patmos in uh exile
he had no clue christ would appear to
him this happened about between 90 and
100 between 60 years after jesus went
back to heaven and he turns and he sees
jesus his master after 60 years
i often wonder what happened and he fell
on the ground
and christ put a hand on him
to strengthen him he he collapsed
when he saw his sweet savior upon whose
bosom he would lean so often nothing
homosexual about that somebody's saying
man quickly
it was a man loving a man
revelation 3 21 do you have that
read with me what does that say
to him that overcometh will i grant to
sit with me in my throne even as i also
overcame and i'm sat down with my father
in his throne now what's the operative
word in that verse overcome
how are we to overcome the way jesus
overcame
in his humanity are you following me
the life jesus lived in human form is
the life required of us because god does
not have two standards for admission to
his kingdom
he has won the righteousness of christ
as lived in human form that's our
standard
and if god requires it it means it's
possible
achievable
by his power
now let's reverse we've been looking at
god is this way requires it of us let's
look at we are to behave one way then
god must be that way let's go to matthew
5.
we'll come of it in a reverse order we
look at our behavior that god requires
of us then we must assume that's the way
god is
matthew 5. let's read from verse 38
we're looking at the sermon on the mount
you have matthew 5
matthew was a tax collector before he
met christ that's a nice way of saying
he was a thief
that's collectors were thieves their
jews hated them they took too much taxes
skimmed off the top and gave the romans
theirs the jews despised them
oh they hated them
but no matter how
bad you may be before you met jesus if
you genuinely collide with christ he
will change your life
and matthew went from being a thief to
being the first gospel writer matthew 5
38.
read with me you have heard that it have
been said what an eye for an eye and a
tooth for a tooth but i say unto you
that he resists not evil but whosoever
shall smite thee come on
on our right shake
turn to him the other also paul's now
jesus says that's the way you should
behave what can we assume
that's the way
god is
if that's not the case there's no image
reflection
let me say it again
jesus says
if someone smites you on one sheet turn
the other
in other words don't retaliate
for him to require that of us tells us
that's the way god is
are you with me that's the way god is
because if that's not the way god is
we're not reflecting his character when
we behave that way
verse 40 what does that say
and if any man will sue the other law
and take away thy court come on let him
have thy cloak also go to
extremes to maintain the peace
uh you're not following me
you're nice looking people but you're
not following
if and oh you heard god bless you
if any man will soothe you at the law
and take away thy coat let him have thy
cloak also so he has nothing to say
the matter is settled
because you went to
x3
are you following me
[Music]
let's look at verse 41
and whosoever shall compel thee to go a
mile come on
go with him twain you silence him by
going to extremes
now if jesus requires us to go to
extremes we can conclude that's the way
god is
now let's look at god going to extremes
before we close already according to
something
go with me
to uh
ezekiel 18.
you know it very well no easy to turn
there the soul that sinneth finish it
it shall die all right
romans chapter 6 verse 23 you also know
that but the wages the the wages of sin
is death
the which sin is death
romans 5 12
for us by one man's sin entered into the
world and death by sin we know the wages
of sin come on is death
we saw it in ezekiel 18 4
romans 6 23
romans 5 12
of course god said in the day thou
eaters thereof come on tell me thou
shalt surely die the wages of sin has
always been death
think with me
did jesus die yes or no
yes
did he pay the wages of sin
yes did he paid fully
yes then why did he rise
wait a minute listen to me carefully
listen to me carefully
what are the wages of sin
did jesus die
then why did he rise
when he died did he pay the wages of sin
yes or no yes
because every person who's lost will pay
the wages for himself
but will never enter heaven
so paying the wages is good but christ
went a step beyond
ah
it's my fault you're not getting it it's
my fault
everyone who's lost
are you with me
will pay for his own sins he'll pay
fully in the flames of hell
but will never enter heaven even though
the sins are paid for
are you following me
then why did christ rise
[Music]
not only to pay the wages of sin but to
make a way for us to live again
and this time live with him eternally
and so christ went beyond
ellen white writes in review and herald
1886 uh september 25 paragraph five
justice demanded the sufferings of a man
jesus equal with god rendered the
sufferings of a god
i said that too quickly let me slow down
appreciably
review on herald
september 21
1886 paragraph five justice demanded
the sufferings of a man why because the
soul that sinneth it shall die it was a
mandate
name him quickly
adam and then we followed him
listen to me again justice
demanded
the sufferings of a man
jesus gave the sufferings of a god
he silenced the devil
are you following me he went to
to do what silence the devil
in others he paid and then he
overpaid
he tipped
you will have nothing to say about the
fullness and the completeness of my
sacrifice i die i will rise again
justice demanded the sufferings of a man
jesus gave the sufferings of a god only
a god could have taken what jesus took
in gethsemane no human being other than
christ could have done that
so he went
above and beyond
he went
to extremes
to save us not only from the penalty of
sin but to grant us an entrance into his
kingdom
there's a god in heaven watching you and
me now
he requires of us to live lives in which
we go
to extremes
listen to uh romans 12 18 you go there
romans 8 12 80 romans 12 18
when you found it say amen
that was fast are you sure you have it
okay
romans 12 18.
i'll give you a little
a couple more seconds to find it 10
minutes to eight do you have it now all
right
i'll be there
read for me if you have the king james
version so there's no confusion in the
reading what does that say if
it be possible stop
if it is remotely possible says god to
us through paul
keep reading now
much as life in you come on
live peaceably with all men in other
words christ is saying go to
extremes to preserve the peace
listen to christ saying the same thing
differently go to matthew 10.
a lot of us get into trouble because we
don't go to extremes
we go to extremes in the wrong direction
do you have matthew 10
let's look at verse 16.
closely remember what we read in romans
12 18 matthew 10 verse 16.
you have that
read for me what does that say
behold i send you forth
a sheep come on in the midst of will
stop
now you can't get two greater opposites
than sheep and wolves
are you with me
for a world sheep is breakfast lunch and
dinner are you following me all right
jesus says i am sending you
in the midst of sheep of wolves now
listen to what he tells them finish that
verse
be therefore
yes uh-huh and harmlessness doubts in
other words do everything in your power
not to antagonize come on
the wolves
what does he tell the wolves to do
nothing
uh have i lost you
he does not make any requirements of the
wolves
so you don't go fussing with city hall
you find a way come on to get along with
the authorities
until they ask you to violate the ten
commandments then we can't do that
we must learn but it requires humility
to go to extremes to get along with
someone trying to hurt you
if the government says in a bishop
what's this place bisbee
wilcox
same thing
if the government says don't wear ties
to church what do we do
we take them off
because there's no commandment that says
thou shall wear a tie
are you with me
if the government says do not sing hymns
in your service what do we do we don't
sing
if the government says work on sabbath
what do we do can't do that
can't do that
if it be possible come on
as much as life in you not the wolves
live peaceably
with all men as much as lay in god
he paid the price for our salvation
because our god went
come on tell me our god went to extremes
is there someone in the church you're
not getting along with swallow your
pride you go take the first step
the person may be your husband sleeping
next to you
or your wife
someone on the job
you've had this grudge for years
you go to extremes
to preserve the peace
because god went to extremes to bring
about peace between himself and the
sinner
and i thank god
for being a god
who goes to extremes
he'll go to extremes in another way
because i have not seen come on no ear
heard neither hath entered into the
heart of man the things which god has
prepared for them that love him when you
and i set eyes on the new jerusalem we
will realize we serve a god who goes to
extremes
because eloise says when christ comes
back the garden of eden will come down
more beautiful than it was
when god originally made it
how many of you will say god thank you
for going to extremes for my salvation
can i say do you mean that stand up with
me
we're going to pray to god
as bow rise close dear god in heaven we
thank you you are a god
who went to extremes to save us
and you require of us their god that
will reflect that aspect of your image
we must go to extremes to protect your
reputation in our lives
up to and including sacrificing our
lives as jesus did
god in heaven there's someone listening
to me who needs to settle a disagreement
with some church member that person
needs to swallow his our pride and go to
extremes of humility to fix that problem
in all that we do god on the job in the
community wherever we are help us to go
the extra mile to turn the other cheek
to god for the sake of peace because in
so doing we are reflecting the image of
god grant us that spirit grant us that
humility to god and we thank you that
christ not only died and paid the price
of sin but he rose to provide an
admission to his kingdom
bless us sustain us and let us
demonstrate in our lives our interaction
with one another how deeply we
appreciate that we serve a god who goes
to extremes watch over us tonight i pray
bring us back tomorrow to hear your word
again we pray in jesus name let god's
people say